[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
alors je suis pierre-yves je suis fable
à manager à l'ubs et open factory
bonsoir à tous je suis mathieu je suis
également fablab manager à l'ubs et aux
open factory alors l'ubs et open factory
c'est un fab lab un atelier de
prototypage et donc ce soir on voulait
parler discuter avec vous sur le fait
d'un la transformation d'un espace de
prototypage vers un outil pédagogique
flexible pour les formations
universitaires
alors on vient déjà dire beaucoup de
termes on a utilisé le mot de
prototypage de fab lab l'atelier de
prototypage de fab lab manager ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va revenir
progressivement sur tous ces termes et
éclaircir tout ça pour vous voilà alors
au départ le prototypage qu'est ce que
c'est par définition c'est créer un
objet unique dans le but de les tester
et finalement faire ça ça revient un peu
à ce qu'on a tous eu l'occasion de faire
dans sa vie c'est à dire du bricolage
donc je vous propose de revenir un peu
sur le bricolage alors le terme
bricolage
en fait le bricolage ça correspond à ce
tout ce que vous faites en dehors de
votre cas de professionnels et qui
consiste à créer modifier et améliorer
ou entretenir un objet alors on a mis
une petite catapulte parce que ça nous a
amusé quand on a un peu recherché ce que
c'était que le bricolage
on s'est rendu compte que bricole la
bricole c'était le mot utilisé pour
qualifier la catapulte au moyen âge et à
la renaissance
quand la catapulte est devenu obsolète
le mot a changé a changé de sens et
c'est devenu moyens détournés et habile
et doux aujourd'hui le bricolage alors
un petit exemple de bricolage qu'on fait
tous chez nous on a tous eu l'occasion
de bricoler de louper des trucs de
réussir des choses
bon on à moi par exemple il m'est arrivé
de bricoler la barrière dans mon jardin
j'ai récupéré des planches
j'en ai acheté d'autres je les ai
assemblée je suis pas menuisier ça
marche pas vraiment mais ça marche un
peu je suis content de l'avoir fait j'en
ressors satisfait voilà j'ai créé un
objet unique que je teste et donc avec
mathieu on s'est posé une question quand
on bricole au-delà du fait de bricoler
qu'est-ce qu'ils jouent pour le
bricoleur qu'est ce qui lui reste au
delà de son objet et il ya trois aspects
qu'ils soient ressortis en fait va
bricoler ces occasions de faire en
apprenant et d'apprendre en faisant
c'est l'occasion de faire preuve de
créativité ou d'exprimer sa créativité
et quand on bricole on a le droit à
l'erreur
on peut se tromper et recommencer son
objet et c'est le bricolage ça se fait
tout seul mais ça peut aussi se faire à
plusieurs avec ses amis ses voisins dans
des associations
c'est ça donc pour continuer un peu
l'anecdote de ma de mon portail chez moi
ben il ya par exemple l'autre jour
j'étais donc
à la fête des voisins au repas des
voisins et puis en plein milieu du repas
vers minuit il me dit que finalement ben
ali lui il est un peu spécialiste des
moteurs de la motorisation et là on
s'est dit tiens peut-être qu'il peut
m'aider à améliorer mon portail est donc
bah finalement d'un portail qui était
manuel qui marche au t1 peu et ben on a
installé un moteur dessus et finalement
ben lui il avait d'autres compétences
que j'avais pas il m'a appris des choses
je lui appris un peu moins de choses
mais en tout cas on a pu faire quelque
chose qui était un peu plus évolués qui
avait un peu plus voilà un peu plus
d'aspects et puis bah sinon là sur
l'image vous pouvez voir quelque chose
qui est assez représentatif donc c'est
les castors je sais pas si vous
connaissez les castors c'est des
personnes qui sont mis en groupe
après la seconde guerre mondiale pour
reconstruire des bâtiments ils sont mis
à plusieurs il avait plusieurs
compétences et donc chacun apporté un
peu sa pierre à l'édifice au bâtiment en
l'occurrence et donc c'est voilà au lieu
d'attendre que les autorités auront
repenser la ville et c'est tard ils ont
reconstruit leurs habitations
et donc c'est une association qui existe
toujours donc c'est des personnes qui se
mettent en groupes qui ont des
compétences et qui ensemble bricole lors
de la même manière avec mathieu on sait
poser une question alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils jouent pour les bricoleurs en
groupe qu'est ce qu'il leur reste au
delà de l'heure de leur création
alors comme on a vu juste au juste avant
bah ils ont pu apprendre en faisant et
faire en apprenant ils n'ont plus pu
faire oeuvre preuve pardon de créativité
ils ont eu le droit à l'erreur mais
surtout et il sait jouer de
l'interaction sociale et pour fêter
l'occasion de partager les connaissances
des compétences et c'est aussi
l'occasion de créer des projets plus
grand plus ambitieux alors le bricolage
en voit à peu près tout ce que sait on
en fait tous plus ou moins on a tous
utiliser un tournevis un marteau une
perceuse mais depuis quelques années en
fait il ya un mouvement qu'un train de
s'opérer où on voit des gens qui
commencent à avoir accès à des outils
piloté par ordinateur
je pense notamment aux imprimantes 3d
une découpeuse laser
offrez 2 à commande numérique et ces
outils là on les retrouve depuis des
années dans l'industrie mais d'une part
grâce à l'open source et d'autre part
grâce à la standardisation ces outils
deviennent de plus en plus accessible
pour le plus grand nombre et ce
mouvement de bricoleurs en groupe s'est
donc dotée de ces outils et ça a créé un
mouvement voilà qu'on appelle le
mouvement des meilleurs donc c'est un
mot anglais qui nous vient tout droit
des états unis dont qui désigne en fait
une communauté de personnes qui bricole
en groupe pour prototype et des objets
donc c'est plus le bricolage
traditionnel où on bricolait des objets
artisanaux là on vient utilisez donc des
machines assistée par ordinateur donc
comme disait pierre-yves les imprimantes
3d etc
d'autres les personnes va se sont mis en
groupe et maintenant prototype plutôt
des objets technologiques qui joue avec
de l'électronique qui joue avec de
l'informatique et donc bah on peut créer
comme ça tout un autre style d'objets
qu'une barrière de jardin est donc un
exemple qui assez représentatifs de ce
mouvement mais coeur donc dans les
années 70 donc il ya un certain steve
jobs et ses compères qui dans leur
garage ont bidouillé un semblant
d'ordinateurs en fait il y décède en il
essaye de regarder comment est-ce qu'on
pouvait rendre accessible informatique à
tout le monde et donc ils ont bidouillé
l'apple 2 sur le principe de
l'ordinateur personnel alors la même
manière on s'est posé la même question
avec mathieu met alors au delà du
mouvement makers
quand ils ont créé par exemple apple
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui s'est joué
pour eux alors ils ont pu encore une
fois apprendre en faisant faire en
apprenant fait preuve de créativité
ils ont le droit à l'erreur ils se sont
trompés ils ont recommencé
tout ça dans un cadre d'interactions
sociales ou n'ont pas pu partager leurs
compétences leurs connaissances et
surtout ils ont pu créer des projets
plus grand plus ambitieux et
technologiques grâce à un accès à des
équipements de prototypage numérique
alors ce mouvement d makers
ils ont commencé à se regrouper dans des
lieux où ils ont commencé à mettre en
commun ses équipements qu'ils avaient
acquis et ces lieux sont donc des
ateliers de prototypage qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les fab lab alors les fab
lab dont pour fabrication de laboratoire
encore un mot qui nous voient qui nous
vient tout droit des états unis donc
c'est un mouvement qui est né au début
des années 2000 là bas qui en fait une
standardisation de tous les ateliers de
maker est en fait qui définit un atelier
on va retrouver des équipements de
bricolage traditionnelle qui servent à
prototyper des choses donc des marteaux
des tournevis etc mais aussi du coup ces
machines à commandes numériques l' issue
du mouvement meeker donc on retrouve une
ressource matérielle mais plus seulement
une ressource une ressource matérielle
on a donc ses meilleurs qui sont dans
ces ateliers de fabrication les fab lab
qui du coup partagent leurs
connaissances mettent à disposition
leurs ressources et en plus de ça on a
donc d'autres personnes des
facilitateurs qu'on appelle les fab lab
manager donc qui sont notre métier a
allumé open factory donc quel est le
rôle de ces personnes dans un fab lab
donc c'est à la fois de coordonner
l'espace de coordonner les projets
d'aidé les utilisateurs sur des points
techniques sur des points méthodologique
de proposer des formations sur des
nouveaux outils et c'est vraiment
essentiel ce rôle là parce que
finalement c'est pas parce qu'on ouvre
un endroit avec un certain nombre
d'équipements qu'on sait forcément les
utiliser donc voilà également la plus
value donc calé fab lab un peu
d'histoire donc ni le sgar jeune fils
qui nous vient tout droit des états unis
à aa a défini ce qu'est le concept fab
lab donc il a à monter pour les besoins
d'un court qu'il avait osé mighty donc
les mighty le massachusetts institute of
technology à boston pour un cours qu'ils
avaient un cours qui s'appelait comment
créer à peu près n'importe quoi ils
avaient besoin d'un atelier de
prototypage là on pouvait bricoler là on
pouvait bricoler avec des outils à
commande numérique comme des imprimantes
3d et du coup il s'est dit que ce serait
bien de standardiser un peu tout ça donc
il a eu l'idée de définir ce que c'était
un fab lab en termes d'outils de
ressources etc
le principe c'est que lorsqu on fabrique
un objet dans un fab lab quelque part
dans le monde on peut potentiellement
fabriquer le même objet dans un autre
pays parce que justement les machines
nos ressources sont sensibles sans si
ble ment les mains
alors du coup on assiste depuis quinze
ans une diffusion des fab lab à travers
le monde
donc au début des années 2000 le premier
fablab à boston comme vient de le dire
mathieu et puis en 2009
voilà 2012 on voit une progression
2015-2017 jusqu'à arriver donc à
aujourd'hui à 511 fablab référencé comme
tel aux prés du hem haïti à boston alors
après des fab lab c'est un très très bon
outil pour prototype et en groupe mais
il en existe de plusieurs sortes
il ya des fab lab qui servent à des fins
associative pour par exemple de
l'éducation populaire
il ya des fab lab qui servent pour les
entreprises pour justement stimuler la
créativité des salariés d'une entreprise
il ya des fables qui sont implantées
dans les écoles il ya des fab lab qui
sont implantées dans les universités et
du coup là sur quelques photos on
illustre quelques fables qui existent
donc là à l'écran on a le fab lab de
toulouse qui est architecte le premier
fablab en france
voilà donc dans ce fablab ya des
personnes qui viennent prototype et il
prototype également avec des entreprises
parce que il ya airbus qui n'est pas
loin aussi à toulouse et donc qui est
partie prenante aussi du fab lab donc
c'est très intéressant pour les bars on
a un autre type de fab lab donc ce coup
ci à barcelone qui s'appelle le green
fablab lula ils vont plutôt travailler
sur des projets en relation avec les
transition écologique énergétique et on
a les prémices des fab lab universitaire
qui apparaissent ici à l'université de
alto en finlande où là ils ont mixé une
faculté des sciences avec une école
d'économie avec une école de design et
du coup là on commence à voir en quoi le
fab lab finalement peut servir en un
outil pédagogique et à créer des projets
transdisciplinaires
donc avec mathieu on a fait encore une
fois le même exercice
qu'est-ce qu'ils jouent pour les lakers
les bricoleurs qui viennent dans les fab
lab commencé à comprendre le propos
ils ont appris en faisant ils ont fait
en apprenant ils ont fait preuve de
créativité
ils ont pu se tromper recommencer tout
ça dans l'interaction sociale pour
partager les compétences les
connaissances avec des projets plus
grand plus ambitieux grâce à un accès
des équipements de prototypage numérique
et ce dans un lieu ouvert à tous le fab
lab encadrés par des facilitateurs donc
les fables manager les fab lab manager
qui les ont orientés sur l'utilisation
des équipements formation aux
équipements et leur donner des apports
sur la gestion l'orientation de leurs
projets du coup en 2015 on s'est dit que
ça serait pas mal de pouvoir mettre un
tel lieu à disposition des étudiants de
l'université de brest et s'est créé le
fab lab de l'université de brest lui bo
open factory il a été créé en
partenariat avec l'école d'arts de brest
est donc le fab lab on le définit comme
atelier ouvert d'innovation
pluridisciplinaire atelier puisque donc
c'est un atelier de prototypage avec les
équipements qu'on a nommé tout à leur
imprimante 3d découpeuse laser par
exemple ouvert puisqu'il est ouvert à
tous les étudiants de l'université
il est ouvert aux enseignants et au
personnel administratif de l'université
d'innovation puisque on va s'intéresser
en priorité à des projets
lié à la ville de demain donc la
transition écologique la transition
énergétique la transition numérique
on va s'intéresser à des problématiques
liées au handicap ou encore à la
fabrication d'équipements pour les fab
lab et pluridisciplinaire puisque ça va
être l'occasion sur un même projet de
voir se rencontrer des étudiants de
cursus différents avoir des étudiants
qui viennent je sais pas de mécanique
d'électronique de biologie de géographie
d'histoire de staps d'économie tous
types d'étudiants donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas un espace conte à couramment
l'habitude de voir dans les universités
où c'est assez cloisonné par discipline
là c'est vraiment une opportunité de
proposer ce genre d'atelier sefa blabla
pour les étudiants pour que lorsqu'ils
ont une idée ils puissent aller
rapidement vers du prototypage tester
leurs idées
donc ça c'est au niveau des machines
après au niveau de l'animation c'est
important de pouvoir faire des projets
de profiter de ce fable abla de cet
atelier ouvert pour mixer justement les
compétences des personnes comme tu as
dit périph qui viennent de fac de
sciences mais aussi de fac de lettres de
fac d'économie c'est vrai qu'on a c'est
de partager ces disciplines comme ça on
a vu que c'était très gratifiant et le
rôle aussi de l'open factory c'est de
faire une connexion avec le milieu
socio-économique c'est à dire que sur la
plupart des projets qu'on travaille à
l'open factory on essaye de connecter un
professionnel ce qui va permettre de
crédibiliser les projets sur lesquels
les étudiants travaillent et donc pour
les étudiants de connaître beaucoup plus
rapidement on espère le milieu
socio-économique
alors voilà ça c'est l'équipe des femmes
managers de l'ubs et open factory donc
on est huit et on voulait mettre cette
photo parce que c'est intéressant parce
qu'on vient on a des compétences
complètement différentes mais
complémentaires
on va retrouver des électroniciens des
mécas trône mécatronicien des
biophysicien des informaticiens des
experts du multimédia des designers ou
des personnes en sciences de l'éducation
donc voilà on voulait vous présenter
quelques projets qui ont lieu
actuellement au moment où on parle à
l'ubs et open factory voilà donc là
c'est le projet donc qui est animée par
guy temps hermès qui sont tous les deux
en deuxième année de licence et donc il
travaille avec des professionnels avec
la compagnie danse moral soul à
l'interactivité des spectacles de danse
et donc là ils sont en train de faire la
conception d'une lampe interactive un
peu pixelisé et qui est arrêté en ce
moment c'est en live en fait et est du
coup pas pour eux c'est très intéressant
parce qu'ils peuvent approcher vraiment
les problématiques du professionnel se
confronter à la réalité des choses à des
choses qui marchent choses qui marchent
pas et pour des étudiants de deuxième
année licence c'est un gros plus le
deuxième projet c'est le projet green
pile de récupération d'énergie par les
plantes
voilà c'est ça donc là c'est un projet
ou en fait on essaie de voir comment est
ce qu'il est possible de récupérer
l'énergie électrique avec des plantes
dans un contexte de murs végétalisés où
on peut imaginer pouvoir faire de
l'éclairage public extérieur de la
signalétique donc là c'est typiquement
un projet pluridisciplinaire avec des
personnes qui viennent à la fois
d'électronique de biologie de chimie de
mécanique d'informatique et donc on voit
très bien que et de design on va très
bien que ce genre de projet et ben s'il
n'y avait pas de fab lab si les pas de
lieux comme ça pour concentrer tous les
idées il aurait du mal à émerger comme
ça naturellement un dernier projet qu'on
peut présenter le projet kraken oui
alors le projet kraken qui est un projet
qui a été piloté par corentin en fin
d'année de master design et de sophie en
master de biologie qui donc se soucier
de qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire avec
les déchets de poisson et en particulier
la peau de poisson
donc ils ont eu l'idée de regarder
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait mettre au
point un système de tannage des peaux de
façon pour en faire du cuir et un
vêtement que voici un très joli manteau
en peau de poisson et donc ça c'est
également un groupe pluridisciplinaire
qui a gagné un prix l'an passé un prix
de l'innovation étudiante donc de la
banque populaire de l'ouest donc à des
5000 euros et du coup aujourd'hui par
potentiellement vert de
l'entrepreneuriat donc ça aussi
grâce au fait qu'ils ont eu à
disposition un atelier de prototypage
pour le tester leurs idées et pouvoir
voilà ça confrontés à des problématiques
réelles pour conclure donc voilà
aujourd'hui dans une université qui
tente à chercher à se décloisonner à
faire se rapprocher les disciplines à
faire en sorte que les monde
socio-économique les mondes des
étudiants le monde de la recherche se
regroupent se retrouve on a donc créé
l'ubs et open factory puisque c'est un
lieu à disposition des enseignants et
des étudiants ou les étudiants peuvent
apprendre en faisant et faire en
apprenant ils peuvent développer leur
créativité
ils ont droit de se tromper en droit à
l'erreur ils ont droit doit recommencer
c'est un endroit où il y aura de leurs
interactions sociales et on espère un
partage des connaissances des
compétences où ils vont pouvoir
concrétiser des idées qu'ils ont en tête
pour créer des objets plus grands
avec grâce à un accès des équipements de
prototypage numérique
c'est un lieu ouvert à tous où il sera
encadré de fab lab manager et c'est en
ça qu'on se positionne aujourd'hui comme
un nouvel outil pédagogique flexible
pour la formation universitaire merci
merci
[Applaudissements]